y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa ya está lista en nuestro
estudio de directo américa rosa pérez
más de un rosa feliz sobre 22 qué bueno
tenerte de nuevo aquí con nosotros en
este estudio de regreso a nuestro
programa vamos empezar entonces a hablar
de lo que estábamos adelantando al
principio de directo américa las 10
personas más ricas del mundo duplican a
su riqueza durante la pandemia de kobe
19 sólo tiene el periódico the gardian
rosa buenos días raúl exacto empezamos
el año de esta sección de revista de
prensa con esta información que hace
referencia a un estudio que acaba de
publicar la organización intermón oxfam
que nos da dos datos para enmarcar este
titular que estabas comentando y es que
si bien desde el inicio de la pandemia
situado aproximadamente en marzo de 2020
bien la mayoría de personas el 99% de la
población mundial ha visto cómo caían
sus ingresos y 163 millones de personas
han caído por debajo del umbral de la
riqueza de la pobreza las 10 personas
más ricas del mundo han visto como sus
ingresos aumentarán de forma exponencial
según nos dice
y si juntamos los ingresos de estas diez
personas de estos diez hombres de hecho
porque en el ranking no figura ninguna
mujer entre todos facturaban más de mil
millones de dólares al día sobre todo
por el aumento de los precios de las
acciones y de los bienes que poseen bien
pues nos fijamos un poco en este gráfico
que incluye el texto y vemos en gris la
riqueza neta de estas personas en marzo
de 2020 y su riqueza actual no vemos
este aumento impresionante a la cabeza
tenemos el on mars cofundador de tesla
seguido de jeff bezos de amazon bernard
nuevo que es el propietario del femás
este grupo de empresas de lujo de
francia bill gates larry ellison larry
page y sergey brin de google no en las
empresas tecnológicas a la cabeza de
este ranking vemos también a mark
zuckerberg entre ellos impresionante lb
long moscú de verdad que es la
comparación es bastante grande rosa
vamos ahora con el país una entrevista a
noam chomsky dice yo crecí durante la
gran depresión pero entonces reinaba una
atmósfera de esperanza porque traemos
esto a colación además le doy un dato
por ahí el jueves se cumple ya un año de
la presidencia de joe biden es por esto
rosa exactamente no la una de las
corresponsales del país en eeuu
entrevista a nuevas oms que recordemos
es una lingüista estadounidense pero
sobre todo reconocido por sus aportes en
el análisis político de la política
tanto nacional como internacional de
eeuu o como por el poder de los medios
de comunicación entonces de cara a este
primer año de mandato de byd en repasan
algunos de los temas que marcan la
actualidad política de eeuu y por
consecuencia del mundo a estas alturas
entre otras cosas jones que reflexiona
que él creció como dice el titular
durante la gran depresión pero que en
ese momento había atisbos de esperanza
sobre construir un futuro mejor por lo
menos en eeuu sin embargo dice en europa
la reacción a la gran depresión fue el
fascismo con franco mussolini o hitler
pero en eeuu la reacción fue la
democracia social moderada con el new
deal de roosevelt entre otras cosas que
luego fue repetida en europa si miras
las democracias actuales europa aún se
agarra la democracia social pero ésta se
encamina al propio fascismo de hecho
dice que el partido republicano ya no es
un partido político sino un partido
neofascista califica el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero del año pasado
como un golpe de estado y dice que en
ese se fracasó pero que se está
construyendo un golpe de estado blando
delante de nuestros ojos que el partido
republicano está modificando leyes
electorales en los estados donde
gobierna para bueno ganar asegurarse la
victoria de forma ilegítima en las
próximas elecciones ros a página/12
seguimos hablando de la pandemia en ese
2022 coronavirus la 3era ola atrajo un
boom de primeras dosis el artículo de
patricia chain exacto repasamos bueno la
situación de la vacunación en argentina
en este caso donde el análisis de adex
de este texto señala que este boom de
casi un millón de nuevas vacunaciones en
argentina se debe a tres factores sobre
todo dice por un lado un cambio de
percepción respecto a estos fármacos por
otro lado el aumento exponencial de
casos en esta tercera ola y sobre todo
la exigencia del pase sanitario que
entró en vigor a nivel nacional este 1
de enero de 2022 vamos a orar con la bbc
porque hay compañías rosa que se están
gastando millones para comprar terrenos
virtuales hablamos el metaverso pues
mira raúl hacemos referencia a un texto
que de forma pues
tangente también toca el tema de las
desigualdades porque lo que vemos es
como el metaverso puede acabar
convirtiéndose también en un espacio
donde las desigualdades sociales y
económicas se traduzcan en desigualdades
urbanísticas porque estamos viendo
grandes inversores privados o
inmobiliarias que compran terrenos que
son limitados en estos mundos virtuales
donde posteriormente se podrán ya se
pueden de hecho hoy en día celebrar
eventos privados por los cuales puedes
cobrar y de hecho vemos como la
explosión por este interés inmobiliario
virtual pues creció de forma importante
cuando facebook se rebautizó el
metaverso no haciendo una gran apuesta
pública por este mundo donde el mundo
físico de hecho se mezcla con el virtual
a través de la realidad aumentada rosa y
entonces el metaverso
es solamente cosa de juegos gracias por
esta primera revista de prensa del año
2022 aquí en directo américa nos vemos
mañana con más vamos a pasar ahora a
nuestro primer invitado del día